welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid Oh al sorry my teleporter seems to
be broken again this does not bode well
anyway I'd like to address a deceivingly
simple question what exactly is freefall
cuz I'm free free fallin as with most
things whether or not you call something
freefall as a matter of definition will
start this video with the basic physical
definition an object isn't free fall
if and only if its motion is limited to
the following conditions gravity is the
only force acting on it and it is only
moving up and down science likes it's
definitions to be specific wait did you
say up why yes yes I did it's a common
misconception that the word fall implies
down but this skateboarder is in
freefall on his way up and down because
gravity doesn't really care which way
you're moving again
really okay so let's further limit
ourselves to ordinary experience you and
I will likely spend our entire lives
here on the earth what no no no we all
know you've been to Space Mountain quit
bragging any way down here gravity
pretty much affects everything the same
everywhere
a typical physics teacher would quote a
number like 9.8 meters per second
squared
that's an acceleration or how fast your
speed changes as you fall in this case
that's 9.8 meters per second per second
no meters per second is great for
scientists but you probably don't have
an instinct for it depending on where
you live you need either miles per hour
or kilometers per hour 9.8 meters per
second is about 22 miles per hour or 35
kilometers per hour so what this means
is you gain 22 miles per hour for every
second that you fall for some
perspective in one second you fall about
16 feet or one and a half stories this
is why people can die from a three-story
fall you're hitting the ground at 44
miles per hour this 22 miles per hour
per second is the same for everything
everywhere on the earth what you don't
believe me
watch this racquetball smiley face guy
if I release these two things at the
same time they should follow each other
all the way down
captain George Kitty same time iPhone
Jetta same time check mate
what do with a piece of paper
racquetball
paper yeah I know it's pink deal with it
same time uh okay so maybe not
everything we have this annoying thing
called air it's always making everything
so complicated air resistance is a force
other than gravity so we could just say
the paper isn't in freefall but don't
all of those things fall through the air
crap you're right I guess it's time to
relax our definition a little skydivers
deal with air resistance all the time
and we still say they're in freefall
technically they're not even falling
straight down because when they started
moving they were on the plane oh this is
getting old real fast there are three
factors that increase the airs influence
a smaller weight a larger surface area
and a longer fall time we can't increase
the papers wait so let's reduce its
surface area racquetball crumpled piece
of paper same time if you fall long
enough you reach something called
terminal velocity for a human skydiver
that's about 120 miles per hour as long
as they're falling like this with their
arms and legs stretched out if you
orient yourself a little differently you
can go a little faster at the filming of
this video the record is held by Felix
Baumgartner who broke the sound barrier
with a maximum speed of 834 miles per
hour or Mach 1 and a quarter and he fell
for almost four and a half minutes
luckily most of the stuff we see fall is
heavy enough small enough or only falls
for a fraction of a second so we ignore
the air most of the time so what if
you're not stuck on the earth that's a
very good question to find out let's go
into space here goes nothing oh crap
not good Oh somebody help me stop it
okay here we are space and there's the
earth down there just chillin the
defined edge of the atmosphere is right
about here about 62 miles up now that 22
miles per hour per second we mentioned
earlier is only the acceleration due to
gravity up to about here which is 20
miles up beyond that it's the
to noticeably shrink in value now the
International Space Station orbits here
at about 257 miles give or take
astronauts don't get very far these days
up there gravity is a little over 19
miles per hour per second so not much
smaller astronauts are not weightless
they're just falling around the earth at
the same rate as the station so they
don't notice their weight any more than
a skydiver does you might be wondering
where the moon is in this picture it
doesn't even fit in view because it's
this far away that's about 240,000 miles
out there gravity is six one thousandths
of a mile per hour per second which
still isn't zero
don't forget the earth still holds on to
it all the way out there this number
might seem really small but then it
takes a whole month to go around the
earth so kind of makes sense okay now
we're back
I actually prefer to travel by teleport
when it's working so convenient I tend
to avoid planes and would only skydive
of my life depended on it would any of
you skydive let us know in the comments
section and if you already have please
share your experience and until next
time remember it's okay to be a little
crazy
you